and speaking of Coldplay there the
soundtrack to Bruce Willis's unseen vow
renewal
beat video was shot by ex Demi Moore and
just posted by Bruce's wife Emma the
couple who celebrated 14 years of
marriage on Tuesday is seen saying I do
again on their 10th anniversary in Turks
and Caicos they tie the knot there with
family in 2009 but this time more
willises were on hand
daughters Mabel and Evelyn were the
flower girls rumor and Scout the wedding
singers
[Music]
my whole life is out of my comfort zone
right now so
there you have it with the 68 year old
actor now battling dementia Emma
revealed she's been working with a
dementia care specialist and says she's
keeping memory safe and alive for the
ones that might not be able to
as for Tom Brady it seems there's no
love loss for Giselle after her divorce
tell-all in Vanity Fair her emotions
were very raw and very palpable she
didn't feel like Tom met her in the
middle I think that was the implication
yeah within 24 hours of Gisele breaking
her silence Tom posted this Ralph Waldo
Emerson quote defining success as
enduring the Betrayal of false friends
it's unclear if that's giselle's shade
but the supermodel also tells Vanity
Fair out April 4th football did not come
between them she had cheered for him for
years and many years in many seasons and
she would have continued to quote if
there's one person I want to be the
happiest in the world it's him believe
me I want all his dreams to come true
Tom has a 375 million dollar analyst
deal with Fox Sports but we're told his
main priority is his kids he's not going
to rush back into work football movies
the booth what's next we're all trying
to figure it out the future happens a
day at a time
foreign